la guerre du vietnam n'en finit plus de
faire des ravages aux états unis se voir
tous les films et les séries télévisées
qui sont consacrés dernière polémique en
date celle sur l'agent orange un produit
chimique utilisé dans les bombardements
américains au vietnam il aurait provoqué
des malformations chez les enfants des
gi's jane fonda qui récemment a regretté
d'avoir autant militer contre la guerre
du vietnam jane fonda participe en ce
moment à des fêtes pour aider les
vétérans du vietnam reportage pôle nord
elle s'appelle brandi schiebel à 8 ans
et s'accroche désespérément à son père
randy est né à moitié sourde et aveugle
ils sont 64 mille enfants comme elle mal
formé de naissance leur père
tous des anciens du vietnam les ses
vétérans à cusset l'agent orange un
défoliant à base de dioxyde déversés sur
les forêts les plaines du vietnam qui
est à l'origine de ces malformations
rien n'est encore prouvé
scientifiquement mais les présomptions
sont fortes depuis dix ans ces soldats
perdus et c'est d'alerter l'opinion
publique américaine
les gens voudraient que ce problème du
vietnam disparaissent moi pas question
d'abandonner
je suis américain et je me suis battu
pour ce pays ce soir là les vétérans
avaient organisé une grande fête pour
collecter de l'argent afin de faire
soigner ses enfants
en effet le gouvernement ne veut pas
payer les frais d'hospitalisation
vedette de cette fête deux grandes stars
du cinéma
jane fonda et robert de niro et jane
fonda n'a pas voulu donner d'interview
c'est en effet la première fois que
l'actrice américaine participer à ce
genre de manifestation jane fonda
célèbre pour ses prises de positions
anti américaines pendant la guerre du
vietnam
mais les anciens eux n'ont pas oublié ce
qu'elle a fait n'était pas tout bon ou
tout mauvais mais il est temps pour un
américain et surtout pour un chrétien de
pardonnez lui pardonner à elle d'avoir
fait une si grave erreur
d'accord mais ce que je ne lui
pardonnerai jamais c'est d'avoir fait
tant de tort aux combattants sur le
terrain
douze ans après la fin de la guerre le
vietnam reste encore une profonde
déchirure